Richard Turpin, better known by his nickname,
Dick, was a legendary highwayman who stalked
the English countryside.
A century or so after his death by hanging
in 1739, Turpin was idealised as a dashing
rogue or gentleman thief type in a multitude
of supposedly factual stories purportedly
based on his life.
In reality, he was not exactly dashing, with
a face covered in pox scars.
More importantly, far from being a lovable
rogue, Dick Turpin was kind of, well, a dick
(see: Why Dick is Short for Richard).
Further, many of his supposed “feats”
were actually gleaned from the lives of less
well-known highwaymen, most notable, Swift
Nick Nevison.
Compared to the ruthless Turpin, Nevison was
practically a gentlemen who, while still very
much a scoundrel compared to more law abiding
citizens, specialized in robbing the rich
(which makes sense because, well, they have
a lot more money than the poor), rarely used
violence and was often astonishingly polite
to many he stole from.
(See: Swift Nick Nevison and His Remarkable
Dash to Secure an Alibi)
In contrast, the reality was that Turpin had
no qualms about brutally beating, mutilating,
raping, or robbing just about anyone, including
the elderly and the infirm.
He once even threatened to roast an old lady
alive if she didn’t tell him and his gang
where she’d hidden her life savings.
As reported by Read’s Weekly Journal on
February 8, 1735:
On Saturday night last, about seven o’clock,
five rogues entered the house of the Widow
Shelley at Loughton in Essex, having pistols
&c. and threatened to murder the old lady,
if she would not tell them where her money
lay, which she obstinately refusing for some
time, they threatened to lay her across the
fire, if she did not instantly tell them,
which she would not do.
But her son being in the room, and threatened
to be murdered, cried out, he would tell them,
if they would not murder his mother, and did,
whereupon they went upstairs, and took near
£100, a silver tankard, and other plate,
and all manner of household goods.
They afterwards went into the cellar and drank
several bottles of ale and wine, and broiled
some meat, ate the relicts of a fillet of
veal &c.
While they were doing this, two of their gang
went to Mr Turkles, a farmer’s, who rents
one end of the widow’s house, and robbed
him of above £20 and then they all went off,
taking two of the farmer’s horses, to carry
off their luggage, the horses were found on
Sunday the following morning in Old Street,
and stayed about three hours in the house.
In another “roasting” incident, they robbed
a 70 year old farmer by the name of Joseph
Lawrence in Edgware.
Dragging the poor old man around by his nose
with his pants around his ankles, they beat
him severely on his backside and head, and
then shoved him down to sit bare-butted on
a fire.
While this was happening, other members of
the gang went and raped one of the man’s
maids.
Over the years though, the “legend” of
Turpin became muddled and rather than being
painted as the rapist and brutal thief he
was, he became a handsome and lovable ne’er-do-well
with a heart of gold, being romanticised in
everything from novels to cheesy 1980s TV
shows.
Turpin’s life of serious crime began with
the Gregory Gang, initially made up of Samuel,
Jeremiah, and Jasper Gregory, along with Joseph
Rose, Mary Brazier, John Jones, Thomas Rowden,
and John Wheeler.
Turpin appears to have become involved with
the gang thanks to their early days of poaching
deer and subsequently needing the services
of a butcher to dispose of it.
Turpin later became more directly involved
with the group when they moved from poaching
to robbing dozens of people of their livelihoods.
Over his years with them, he was complicit
in torture, beatings, rape as well as committing
at least one murder (a gamekeeper called Thomas
Morris who’d tried to capture Turpin as
he was hiding in Epping forest but was instead
shot by him).
As a result of all this, the water was getting
hot around Turpin, as members of the famed
gang were getting snapped up by bounty hunters.
After the murder of Morris, The Gentleman’s
Magazine noted in June of 1737:
It having been represented to the King, that
Richard Turpin did on Wednesday the 4th of
May last, barbarously murder Thomas Morris,
Servant to Henry Tomson, one of the Keepers
of Epping-Forest, and commit other notorious
Felonies and Robberies near London, his Majesty
is pleased to promise his most gracious Pardon
to any of his Accomplices, and a Reward of
200l. to any Person or Persons that shall
discover him, so as he may be apprehended
and convicted.
Turpin was born at Thacksted in Essex, is
about Thirty, by Trade a Butcher, about 5
Feet 9 Inches high, brown Complexion, very
much mark’d with the Small Pox, his Cheek-bones
broad, his Face thinner towards the Bottom,
his Visage short, pretty upright, and broad
about the Shoulders.
After this, Turpin attempted to hide from
the law by assuming the identity John Palmer
and absconding from the London area, eventually
finding his way to a small town in Yorkshire
bordering the river Humber called Brough,
presenting himself as a down-on-his-luck butcher
who now made a living as a horse trader.
turpin2Had he at this point turned himself
into a law-abiding citizen, Turpin likely
would have gotten away with the countless
nefarious exploits of his youth.
However, old habits die hard and to fund his
new life, Turpin would often travel across
the river from Yorkshire to nearby Lincolnshire
to steal sheep and horses.
However, the event that really sealed Turpin’s
fate is when he shot a man’s cockerel supposedly
after a failed hunt in 1738 resulted in a
frustrated and drunken Turpin deciding to
take his aggression out on the cock.
In truth, whether Turpin shot the cockerel
to eat or just because he was annoyed isn’t
really clear from contemporary reports from
the time.
All we know for sure is that the owner of
the cockerel was understandably a little angry
at Turpin and confronted him for the shooting.
Turpin, rather than profusely apologising
or offering to pay for the animal or something
like that, instead decided it would be best
to threaten to kill those rebuking him; they
then went straight to the authorities.
After being placed under arrest, the authorities
became deeply suspicious about their town’s
relatively new resident, since they had no
record of his existence before a year previous
and there was some suspicion on how exactly
he actually made a living.
Under questioning, Turpin stuck to his story
and claimed he was a down on his luck butcher
from Lincolnshire called John Palmer, who
now dealt in horse trading.
When the Justices of the Peace questioning
Turpin asked their colleagues in Lincolnshire
if they’d ever heard of John Palmer, they
replied that they had, as he had spent approximately
nine months there.
Unfortunately for Turpin, they also noted
that he was suspected of sheep and horse rustling
and that he’d previous escaped custody when
they tried to question him.
Realising they might be dealing with a greater
crime than they’d initially suspected- killing
a game cock being a relatively minor offence
compared to stealing horses, which was among
the close to 200 capital offences at the time
in England- “Palmer” was transferred to
the dungeons at York Castle on the 16th of
October, 1738.
Growing increasingly desperate for character
references that likely would have seen him
walk free (the hard evidence against him was
scant concerning the horse theft), Turpin
penned a letter to his brother-in-law, Pompr
Rivernall (married to Turpin’s sister, Dorothy),
in the hopes of getting such references.
Unfortunately for Turpin, Pompr took one look
at the handwriting on the cover of the letter
and refused to pay the postage fee, supposedly
stating, he “had no correspondent at York”.
Exactly why Rivernall really refused the letter
is a matter of some debate.
There are some who believe that Rivernall
really didn’t know who the letter was from
or that he was too tight-fisted to fork out
the sixpence necessary to receive it.
Others speculate Rivernall knew that the letter
was from Turpin and simply refused to pay
because he was either tired of being associated
with his wife’s brother or scared of getting
involved in his affairs.
Whatever the reason, the letter ended up being
sent back to the postmaster’s office in
Saffron Walden, Essex.
As fate would have it, the postmaster in Saffron
Walden was none other than James Smith, the
man who’d taught Turpin to read and write
at the village school some two decades before.
Smith, supposedly recognising the handwriting
of his most infamous student on the cover,
paid the postage himself and took the letter
to the local magistrate who gave him permission
to open it to discern its contents, with Smith’s
hope being the contents would confirm his
suspicions.
If confirmed, this would entitle Smith to
the 200 pound reward on Turpin’s head, which
is approximately £20,000 (about $27,000)
today.
After discovering that, indeed, the letter
did appear to be from Turpin and it had been
sent from York Prison, Smith traveled to York,
fingered Turpin, and collected his reward.
Although Turpin was seemingly caught because
of his evidently distinctive handwriting,
no known example of it has survived, meaning
we actually have no real idea how Turpin’s
former schoolmaster was able to recognise
it after two decades.
It’s very possible he simply knew the letter
was to the brother-in-law of Dick Turpin,
with Turpin’s whereabouts unknown, and the
letter’s origin was from a place Rivernall
otherwise didn’t have a correspondence.
Thus, perhaps he simply suspected the letter
was from Turpin in the first place, with the
writing on the cover perhaps having little
to do with his suspicions, despite what he
said to the magistrate.
Or maybe Turpin really did have quite distinct
hand-writing, or distinct enough that with
other suspicions Smith was able to put two
and two together.
Whatever the case, though the evidence against
Turpin concerning the horses he allegedly
stole was scant, now that the locals knew
he was the famed highwaymen, any chance of
him getting off from lack of evidence went
away and he was tried and convicted on several
counts of horse theft.
At his trial, Turpin noted that he wasn’t
given enough time to prepare a proper defence
for himself and that he’d been told the
trial would take place in Essex, not York,
and so hadn’t bothered to get witnesses
in his defence to come to York.
(At the time in England, suspected criminals
were not given legal counsel or representatives,
and instead, lacking funds to pay for such
council, had to defend themselves, including
somehow organising witnesses for their defence
all while sitting in prison.)
As for his execution, the city of York didn’t
have an executioner.
Instead, it was customary to grant a prisoner
a pardon in return for their services in this
role.
As the fates would have it, the executioner
who ended up hanging Turpin just so happened
to be one of his old partners in crime, Thomas
Hadfield.
Rather than go out begging for his life, Turpin
spent some of his ill-gotten funds to purchase
a fine set of clothes to wear to his execution,
as well as hired a group of mourners to follow
him to the gallows.
It was also noted that he “behav’d himself
with amazing assurance [and] bow’d to the
spectators as he passed”.
Further, according to an issue of Gentleman’s
Magazine on the day of Turpin’s hanging,
“Turpin behaved in an undaunted manner;
as he mounted the ladder, feeling his right
leg tremble, he spoke a few words to the topsman,
then threw himself off, and expir’d in five
minutes.”
And so it was that on April 7, 1739 at the
age of around 32, the infamous highwayman
Dick Turpin ceased to be.
He was laid to rest in the grounds of nearby
St George’s church.